dwayne johnson continues to give back
and for his latest act of goodwill oh
such good will he gifted his very own
custom pickup truck that's crazy it's so
amazing to navy veteran oscar rodriguez
it's this stuff that dwayne johnson does
best after reading about all that oscar
has done for his own community dwayne
surprised him at a special screening of
red notice take a look at this
ladies
[Applause]
there's a dude here i read his story and
i was really impressed with the story
too i want to highlight him his name is
oscar rodriguez where are you get out of
here
[Applause]
your story really moved me because i
hear that um you're a personal trainer
right you're always keeping it positive
yeah and motivational and optimistic
you're a leader in your church yeah west
side church
[Applause]
yes you support and you help make meals
for women victims who've been abused by
domestic violence yes
that's a really amazing work i love that
you take care of your mom who's 75. yeah
yeah come on man mama's boys
i wrote this card for you it's a little
thing
what the heck
thank you for your service brother enjoy
your neutral
what the heck is happening
get out of here bro oh my god
you do a lot of good for people man
you do a lot of good for people
i thought this was your truck bro it is
my truck
[Music]
this is my personal truck it's yours now
yo what the heck
start her up
yo i can't see i can't tell you how many
times i see you in this truck it's my my
baby
do a lot of good for people